le maire du laurens président du
rassemblement des forces laurie noisette
avec nous dans son caddie ce matin
bonjour jusque là par fils je vous
maurice viaud le ton et bonjour à tous
les martiniquais
vous êtes là pour évoquer votre départ
d' ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
mais avant d'évoquer se moquer et
souvent les politiques à justin pamphile
élus que vous êtes ne peut pas rester
sans réaction à ce qui a alimenté toutes
les discussions cours du week-end
l'intervention de kemi seba ix2 200
personnes âgées dit pas vendredi dernier
que pensez vous de cela
non je dis franchement des choses je
n'apprécie pas il ya peut-être des
personnes qui ne ne vont pas apprécier
ce que je vais dire là et je trouve que
il y a des il ya des moments où on peut
dire les choses mais ce que j'appelle
des voies de fait comme j'ai assisté
tous les réseaux sociaux menons je ne
partage pas cette manière de faire il
s'en est pris un set ball dit il pour
justifier cette il ya d'autres
intentions
si vous voulez il ya d'autres symboles
sous lesquelles on aurait pu taper et
personne ne l'a fait non je n'ai pas
envie d'épiloguer sur ça mais je vous
dis simplement que je ne je ne partage
pas cette méthode et cette manière de
faire est singulièrement ce que j'ai
constaté c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes martiniquais mais qui semble être
que dans la dynamique qui était posée
j'ai trouvé ça arrive à justin pamphile
c'est parce qu'il ya une faille quelque
part pas une fois une faillite peut-être
du système non je ne crois pas qu'il
veut tous les cantons
moi je suis un jeune politicien qui n'a
pas failli jeu puis mes engagements
moment il fallait les prendre donc
simplement est-ce que prendre ses
engagements c'est investir un magasin
récupère un sachet de sucre et faire que
ce soit en étendard de la révolte de ce
que l'on dit ne pas avoir sculpté aïeux
2009 justin par fils parce que montréal
me manquera son délire du pour dire il y
a de la profitation il ya trop de
différences il n'y a pas d'explication
dans des écarts de prix par yeux qu'on
savait j'ai pas envie de faire de kemi
seba le monde est bas simplement je dis
que les gens n'ont qu'à aller regarder
sur internet et veron qui il est donc je
ne vais pas épiloguer de ce film après
quand même
il faut qu'il ya un après kémi séba
génie pas non c'est fort à une question
d'après kémi séba je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui est connu aujourd'hui au
niveau national les gens savent qui il
est il et il a une
il a une histoire il a entre guillemets
un curriculum vitae jeunes invitent les
gens à aller où regarder tout simplement
pas capable de répondre aux besoins des
plus élémentaires d'une population qui
se rend bien compte que notre île est
champion du monde dans une discipline de
kankan politiques et humaines pour gérer
les affaires c'est autre chose
alors les élus qu'est ce qu'on fait là
aujourd'hui
vous vous êtes vous étiez membres
d'ensemble 1000mercis clauzel vous
claquer la porte vous partez et c'est ça
le modèle que les parties non non c'est
pas du tout ça vous à dire que c'est
comme ça que vous résumer ma démarche
ma démarche n'est pas une démarche de
coco ma démarche est simplement une
manche je dis les choses est-ce que dire
les choses c'est faire du concorde
on m'a trahi non non non mais j'y arrive
j'arrive
j'y arrive quand l'élection s'est
terminée vous m'avez pas entendu ni
crier ni à unias région mais j'écris
mais comme je dis mais c'est ça la
démocratie
c'est à dire c'est avoir cette capacité
de dire les choses la liberté d'être et
de penser et par conséquent je ne suis
pas dans le camp quand je ne suis pas
dans la dispute je suis simplement à un
instant de ma vie politique ou jeudi la
vie politique ne peut pas être une vie
de trahison alors c'est vrai certains
avant moi ont dit que en politique vous
avez moult trahison mais je dis que la
vie politique avec des gens avec qui
vous construisez quelque chose ne peut
pas être une vie trahison par contre à
partir du moment où vous constatez que
les choses ne vont pas dans le sens de
ce que ça devrait vous vous arrêtez vous
ne vous n'allez pas en permanence se
continuer à fonctionner avec des
personnes qui ne vont pas dans le même
sens que vous ne serez pas financée par
le nouvelliste tout simplement qui a vu
que non du côté dans marchés ramène
l'air est un petit peu plus frais c'est
sincèrement que je j'ai pris la décision
de quitter ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle simplement parce que j'ai j'ai
pris une orientation qui serait d'être
membre du comité polissonne rien à voir
du comité politique dans sa salle a
absolument rien à voir il y a simplement
que j'ai pris le temps de la réflexion
après une année qui se ce qui s'est
écoulé nous sommes je vous rappel en
juin
j'ai plus le temps de la réflexion j'ai
plus
la discussion avec mes camarades
politiques et pour être complet il faut
dire aussi que vous aviez déjà annoncé
suffisamment tôt votre votre sympathie
pour emmanuel marché j'ai même dit à un
moment donné que je trouvais que
l'animation d'un symbole martinique
nouvelle n'était pas suffisante
donc j'ai été clair j'ai pas je n'ai pas
et pour emmanuel macron j'ai été le
premier en martinique qui a dit qu'il
choisissait que je choisissais cette
orientation là donc je n'ai pas je ne me
suis jamais caché
et à chaque fois que j'ai eu quelque
chose à dire je les fais maintenant
certains n'apprécient pas que la manière
dont je le fais je serai grande cible
est très clairement le parti
progressiste martiniquais et si les
patrons j'ai ciblé des personnes
peut-être qu'il ya un moment donné n'ont
pas été suffisamment clair avec moi et
je vous l'avais appelé discuter nous
nationale dren et jusqu'à présent celui
avec qui je discutais avec qui je n'ai
aucune difficulté c'est le sous
secrétaire général dit johnny jaj
échanges avec lui j'ai partagé avec lui
les éléments dont je débats avec vous et
pas celui seulement il y en a d'autres
avec qui j'ai discuté je n'ai de conflit
avec personne je le dis je les
martiniquais on a assez d'entendre les
gens se battent se disputait alors que
ce qui nous intéresse fondamentalement
c'est de savoir comment on peut gérer ce
pays et pour gérer ce pays il faut
revenir à ce que j'appelle une sérénité
entre guillemets nationale ou regarder
quelles sont les vraies difficultés les
vrais problèmes qui sont en face de nous
et puis voir comment avec des personnes
qui ont ce ce que j'appelle ce
franc-parler aimé pouvoir se mettre
autour d'une table et puis travailler
pour le pays c'est ça oui mais je sais
ça fait ça fait mayonnaise ça fait sauce
mais c'est comme ça qu'on peut sortir ce
pays de l' entrave dans laquelle il
était pas fils quand même vous avez
expliqué également vous avez dit très
clairement qu'il faudrait quand même que
le gouvernement puisse avoir une autre
son de cloche que celui relayée par les
parlementaires ça veut dire que
catherine conconne ne fait pas le job
que maurice antiste fait c'est parce que
j'ai eu le job serge letchimy le fait
dans la salle parce que j'ai dit alors
je pose la question je répète ce que
j'ai dit j'ai dit simplement que ceux
qui sont dans l'opposition de
gouvernements ne peuvent pas être ceux
qui disent ce qu'il faut pour ce pays et
par conséquent il faut que dans le pays
qu'il y ait des rôles est martiniquais
en capacité d'être plutôt dans une
je dirais en amitié ou en proximité avec
le gouvernement pour permettre de faire
écho des besoins vous vous rendez compte
que si le seul éco qu'on entend c'est
celui de ceux de personnes qui ne
partagent pas jeudi d'autres
orientations que tous les martiniquais
non je crois que ça n'est ni contre
catherine ce n'est ni contre certain
nombre de députés
c'est surtout pour dire qu'il ya le
député qui ouvertement affichent leur
opposition forte et qu'il exprime
vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement et je pense
qu'il yad'autres martiniquais qui
peuvent dont on peut entendre la voix et
dire les choses aux gouvernements en
marche et très adroit absolument pour
juste non non non en marche n'est pas
plus un train à prendre beau juste mon
sol train c'est celui de la martinique
mon seul train c'est celui des
martiniquais et si au travers d'un
groupe de personnes qui aujourd'hui ont
constitué le comité politique dans
marche et qui constituent le parti
politique d'un marchand martinique
on peut faire écho de la voix
martiniquaise ben oui je le fais mais je
le fais je dis sans animosité et sans
conflit avec qui que ce soit alors juste
à profit d' puisque vous avez un canal
privilégié avait contenu de votre
appartenance à en marche martinique vous
avez ce canal privilégié pour vous
adresser aux membres de ce gouvernement
à emmanuel macron vous lui direz quoi
concernant la martinique
quelle est la priorité absolue au moment
par exemple des jeunes vont entrer dans
leur session d'examens scolaires
obligations d'orientation au c'est ce
qui se passe avec notre jeunesse qui a
plutôt envie de partir de la martinique
c'est quoi la priorité numéro un pour
vous la priorité numéro une pour moi en
ce moment c'est de faire en sorte que le
problème que vivent un certain nombre de
martiniquais en l'occurrence la question
du traitement des sargasses qui est
devenu aujourd'hui une considère une
priorité majeure de de santé publique et
qui touche à un certain nombre de villes
de la côte atlantique en particulier
puis quelques villes de la côte caraïbe
aimé que ce problème sera lié à des
ministres qui vont arriver prochainement
et je pense qu'il faut régler ce
problème la pause qui concerne les
jeunes martiniquais
c'est pas comme emmanuel macron qui peut
régler ce problème il faut que nos six
martiniquais aimé que nous puissions
dans le disco qui est prôné dans
l'éducation que nous donnons dans
l'exemplarité que nous sommes aimés que
nous puissions montrer aux jeunes
martiniquais
que ce pays n'est pas justement un pays
de kankan et que la passion et
l'ambition aspect des choses et du
travail certainement et l'ambition que
nous avons et la mission comme beaucoup
de personnes dans ce pays doit appeler à
un moment donné qu'on sorte des discours
de division et qu'on arrive a dit aux
jeunes martigues d'avoir confiance dans
leur pays c'est ce discours là que je
prône c'est ce disque houle et pour
avoir confiance dans ce pays
eh bien il faut faire des choses c'est
pas la gabegie contrairement à ce qu on
peut entendre ici ou là c'est pas non
plus la théorisation excessive mais la
juste investi le juste investissements
et qui permet aux jeunes de trouver
raison à rester dans leur pays ou à
revenir parce qu'ils se sont formés à
l'étranger
ils ont acquis l'expérience à l'étranger
et qui sont capables aujourd'hui de
revenir apporter leur expérience dans
notre groupe d'attractivité de notre
territoire mais c'est le seul disque ou
qu'il faut tenir aux jeunes martiniquais
pas d'autre dit au martini l'arrêté nos
tests il nous reste quatre minutes le
jeu les plongeons les accords il nous
reste quatre minutes essaie de le
convaincre moi essayer de me couvrir
comme moi pourquoi mes enfants vos
enfants nos enfants qui sont partis
faire des études qui aurait intérêt à
revenir dans ce pays mais je suis pas
être celle des études où il est
impossible de se déplacer ne serait ce
que pour nourrir rendez-vous parce qu'il
ya pas de transport public parce qu'on
ne peut pas tout simplement à l'après
midi à la prendre un petit bain de mer à
la plage parce qu'elle est sans gaza
c'est la nature et celle de leur pays
qu'il faut blâmer monsieur viol dont il
faut blaj c'est le prix du billet je
laisse moi aller jusqu'au bout c'est pas
le pays qu'il faut blâmer si les
modalités de gouvernance de ce pays
qu'il faut blâmer
alors vous pensez sans rire c'est la
polynésie mais c'est ce jeudi ou alors
je vais dire aux martigues ne revenait
pas dans votre pays mais s'est pas
laissée pas le pays martin le pays
martinique est un faux un pays
formidable avec des gens qui se lèvent
tôt le matin c'est donc à travers ce en
dépit au projet pied passait très bien
l'ajoulote clock a dit on ne vous
accordera pas de prêt monsieur c'est la
gouvernance c'est-à-dire la gouvernance
dans ce que vous venez dénoncer les
dispositifs bancaire c'est la
gouvernance quelquefois politique c'est
la gouvernance culturelle si la gouverne
c'est à dire que nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un carrefour dans un groupe où il
faut prendre des décisions et pour
prendre des orientations
il est temps que nous puissions je lui
ai
des équipes qui ont envie de faire
bouger ce pays sorti du cancan et puis
je regarde autour de nous dans le monde
il ya des pays insulaires qui
réussissent des pays insulaires qui ne
sont pas forcément des pays français des
pays insulaires qui sont des pays
français et qui réussissent alors
pourquoi nous notre insularité deviendra
un handicap
jeudi la martinique n'est pas plus de
lettres vous venez vous venez de protée
du doigt le politique
je n'ai pas ce que je n'ai pas pointé du
doigt que le de retraite le trajet d'une
manière globale il y a un problème lié à
la gouvernance et cette gouvernance là
est une gouvernance qui doit procéder
par l'exemplarité et quand vous ne
renvoyez qu'une image de catastrophisme
de défaitisme jeudi comment voulez vous
que ceux qui regardent le pays puisse
avoir envie d'y travailler
ils n'ont qu'une idée c'est sortir de ce
marasme l'a bien nous arrivons à un
moment où le flat choisi cette
gouvernance je ne je ne je ne suis pas
en train de remettre en question le
choix du peuple
je suis simplement en train de dire
quelle va être l'organisation et les
choix de demain si les choix de domaine
sur les mêmes et bien les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets eh bien il
faut que nous puissions nous
martiniquais nous organiser pour que ce
qui va se passer demain ne ressemble pas
à ce qui s'est passé hier
il vaudrait pour des cures désarroi des
martiniquais qui disent il a eu une
équipe auparavant on les a pas regardés
il ya une équipe on attendre un petit
peu porteuse jugement définitif
aujourd'hui une troisième voie ce serait
quoi la démocratie à sa de formidables
que quelquefois ceux qui travaillent ou
ont beaucoup travaillé ne sont pas ceux
qui sont reconduits mais il aura fallu
six entraînements il aura fallu
certainement que l'on puisse faire la
comparaison de ce qui a été de ce qui
est et demain de ce qui sera pas ce
qu'il va falloir faire un choix pour
savoir comment jeu des partis comme
enjeu j'organise mon choix et je crois
que la démocratie a de formidables que
chaque martinique est demain au moment
où il faudra faire un choix a entre ses
mains le pouvoir de 10 de dire que voilà
ce que je veux pour mon pays merci
justin pamphile mère du loret président
du rassemblement des forces loury noise
également causé territoriale
d'opposition merci d'envoyer dans ses
enquêtes
merci beaucoup bonne journée et puis
bonne fête des mères